bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti verso
nuovo video sono fa vj e oggi siamo
tornati sul sequestro altri ragazzi
altro giorno guardavo ma siamo arrivati
tipo all'episodio 43 o 44 madonna
abbiamo fatto un casino
cos'è la scusa ma perché se guardando il
telefono mentre si guida un cazzo no no
no war chiossone perfetto che casi
ragazzi questo vi insegna non guardare
mai il telefono mentre si guida un treno
ho già pagato la è si fece allora io io
non ho mai visto una meta o cazzo cosa
diavolo sul tema della famiglia perché
la m mi ha vomitato 1 pesa la cosa mi
sono perso della vita di livelli strani
io ne ho fatti e poi lo sapete anche
ragazzi mamma così ce ne vuole
bisogna essere dei geni che non è
possibile che noi sta a fare un livello
di merda ti prendo a schiaffi e qualcuno
di voi si farà la domanda ma dov'è che
cielo il manubrio in questo momento è io
non risposto al non ve la dose proprio
intelligente socio comunque questo non
si smentisce mai come cosa fatta a
mancarmi un arpione di 12 metri ragazzi
selfin sull'arcobaleno loro sforzo lo
faccio io è una cosa ho anche vinto tra
un nuovo me destro livello era epico
perfetto adesso si parte con livelli più
seri al detroit
non devono non devo sorpassare saline a
qualcosa mi di inserisse cioè una roba
tipo
no ragazzi cosa è successo
ragazzi il suo livello epico perché ti
pigliano in tutti i modi possibili
immaginabili ragazzi voglio un [ __ ]
oscar plus acrobazie perché sono sono
sono un delfino mi son rotto le balle di
farmi passare la farmacia non piccoli
ecco luca su ok
sono io sono io sono vivo solo vivo cosa
ho fatto
cosa sto facendo calming se se ho vinto
e bello è melo pupi non sono anche chi
sei ma me ne frega niente
freeze war che cos'è sta roba mi chiami
mi spaventa già una welcome to my
facebook chris go forward che va bene e
devo andare
si blocca a ragazzi ho capito si
bloccano sti cosi io devo andare avanti
prima che si blocchino poi si senza
braccia che sarà forte ok merda sempre
più difficile io non vado in bici vado
ad addominale la forza del bene tutto è
vero o lei o lei
si vive ma sto tizio cia dei problemi si
celi ha seri di problemi ma in qualche
modo sto livello si può fare senza tipo
rimanere incastrati ma chi è ma cos'è
sto schifo e secondo me il no però vabbè
tanto odio che chi se ne fotte la mia
gamba ce la farà 62 gol
cos'è sta cosa ma lasciare che le bombe
tottino il pavimento rosso dalla tua
parte
no amica che devo devo batterlo
terminati a te devo lanciarla ho vinto
io vincerò bravo bravo
chi è che la prenda arcula ok mi sa che
la prendo io cazzo zucca ragazzi e
bellissimo tratto come seduto nonno ciak
in tribuna bellissima ma posta che parma
donna che palle che sei tu non è
fortissimo no no no cazzo già posso fare
ciò posso fare
eccolo lì per mi chiamavano il
pallavolista chiama ragazzi imposti è un
oscuro sto tizio di angela macchina che
la madonna livello etico ragazzi ho
vinto io ma questo si sa per green world
trovo che sia cristo è fatta lo farà
gara ragazzi voglio farlo a caso senza
guardare voi voglio vedere se esco a
fare qualcosa anche se ne dubito lo ha
beccato un cazzo sì stavolta si sentirà
se io sento la gente che si spappola ma
non vedo niente dove creò uno dietro
vero che non va
come cazzo ho fatto non ho voglio vedere
replay stavolta non ho capito io non ho
io non ho visto niente zero prenderlo
dietro lo spiegate è impossibile ho
fatto tipo no che questa questa mia
andata di culo ma in una maniera
impressionante lo swing in italiano
perché sono volte a cinque stelle
devo portare il livello 5 stelle oppure
una propaganda politica non l'ho capita
questo avvio lo ci gioco lo stesso me ne
sbatto premi z primo getto che perfetto
allora questa ce la posso fare
mickey è difficile ho già visto il
traguardo mancato con un fatto non di
carlo ho mancato e c'erano 450 traguardi
e l'ho mancato fantastico dove cosa
se il nuovo chuck norris vuota 5 st
ancora mio dio va bene 99 100 imposto
proprio così e spero la pantalla io
spero la nutella poi non lo so ma
vestiti
cosa hanno visto cosa è successo
ho visto che se che si è fermato mi son
preso malissimo però ho vinto quindi va
bene così ragazzi stand anche fisso
questo questo faccio e sono un fenomeno
ragazzi ormai faccio parte dei
professionisti cosa ho fatto adesso va
bene
ecco forse forse stavolta lo leggermente
marcato però non lo so non l'ho quasi
tirati su bravo addominale amico mio
misseri boltro cos'è sta roba è una roba
tipo mister mystery boltro non sai che
cosa che cosa c'è all'interno finché la
palla non va dentro e [ __ ] come
faccio come faccio a trovare la vittoria
me tutto sta merda
ok a me donne biscotti e bella vita cioè
ho tirato a caso beccato un no thing
perfetto che sono beccato una se.ga mi
stai prendendo per il culo cena fino
alla terza lo so io niente regali e leo
con uno è forte è forte non c'è verso
che botta di culo
lo chiamo altre ragazze poi basta cioè
che sono troppo oculato quindi mi sembra
impossibile forze sono basta basta
ultima occhi chiusi l'ultima chiusi
ragazzi voglio voglio provarci perché
prima ci sono riuscito cioè con suor
trovo di provare adesso
[Musica]
macché botta di culo cross su in debito
con rob su indecente stavolta ce la
possiamo fare che non sia italiano o lo
fai con luke
si no luke che non hanno mai visto gli
occhi che fa un rock swing ci sarebbe
una roba in crediti che non ha le
braccia come cazzo fa non averle bra
dove gli e dove lei dove la messa
ecco e che mi capita quando esco di casa
mi dimentico le braccia ragazzi mi
succede spesso però non ha veramente li
occupa farei lo swing non lo sapevo
chiesta cosa una figata
e non lo ha mai detto nessuno dovevo
andare meglio su un fenomeno
sei una merda
[Musica]
ragazzi vuole provare a fare una cosa
non farmi un attimo ci sono riuscito
ecco il figlio mio tu che cosa è
successo
no merda ce la sto facendo e bellissimo
sto livello solo per le cagate che puoi
fare da si sta squassando la vicina sì
sì sì sì ok ho fatto l'ho fatta non
chiedetemi con va bene così giuro che è
l'ultima ragazzi perché mi stanno
accadendo i maroni sì se stavolta sì 1
no vinto però va bene ogni importante
sono arrivato quindi va bene così è
stato un casino don't altri non
altrimenti skype questo non l'ho fatto
ma cazzo faccia passare visto buco
un'edizione che a mangia di meno ed
si no sì il casco ma ha salvato il
didietro compito non sennò fate non so
come ho fatto
va bene così mettete sempre il casco
sempre torture rooms mio zio torturare
qualcuno l'ha fatta che sia gli un
demone cos'è il demone ragazzi la prima
sono curioso di vedere che perché c'è
una bambina assatanata sul soffitto
ragazzino questo può da questo poi mi
sono sbagliato dire a questo colpo
giorno uscirà questo parco papa dobbiamo
andare cos'è questa magia devo time to
magic utile la sic fail ha sì uno che
ovviamente va a comprare il latte torna
a casa e inciampa giustamente succede
una cosa normale arciere mio dio katniss
everdeen di sicuro non avrà personaggio
incredibile mira perché deve mirare alla
mela era roba l'hai presa a bra bra vero
no vabbè cos'è di nel paese delle
meraviglie ed araba del già chi è sta
tizia pinzon than the tourist andam
fiore
qui ad allenarlo ed ho capito tutto
la mia pronuncia in tedesco è qualcosa
di raffinato comunque dobbiamo andare ma
che c'è una mosca mi fa veramente non mi
è caduta addosso però in compenso mi è
caduto il ramo alla ragazzi vediamo di
non farci incavola è la devo baciarti
perché devi diventare un principe
azzurro non ho capito ma guardati bacio
con la mia posizione molto sexy è una
cosa molto molto bene va bene però non
ti piazzare voi dovete spiegarmi che mi
chiami direi cadere ogni 4 secondi una
roba sulla testa non è possibile una
leva cos'è cos'è accaduto ovvero ragazzi
è caduto un masso
dove sono sono piombato nella stanza di
un ragazzino fantastico mi dispiace se
ti rubo un monitor no perché vedo che
nei tanti grazie fuochi jane kresimir
impossibile speciale per il milione di
cos'è va bene non è lo speciale ragazzi
però va bene cazzo lo stavo facendo sono
morto malissimo
si no [ __ ] bomba fatti i cazzi
tuoi
non è domandato non di morire di sete
non so se te ne sei accorto però sta in
volto hsupa vigesse un vero fan è vero
lo stimo troppo ubriachi che possono
chiudere qui per oggi perché ne ho
abbastanza di morti euro sto casino king
ragazzi servizi che ha vissuto la sotto
il momento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come la divide una
descrizione se avresti destinazioni ci
vediamo al prossimo vita ci vediamo al
prossimo video l'ho già detto noi ci
dividiamo non possiamo video senza parte
alla cassetta bella ragazza